i'm david thorburn
director of the communications forum it
is my pleasure to introduce our speakers
for today
the the event is going to be moderated
by my colleague henry jenkins
uh who has written widely on uh uh
science fiction
and he's going to be uh in conversation
with one of mit's most distinguished and
legendary writing teachers and writers
joe haldeman who's the author of
numerous novels including
including the nebula award-winning and
hugo award-winning books the forever war
and forever peace collections of short
stories and poetry which i learned today
he began writing before he began writing
his fiction
his latest books are war stories and a
separate war and other stories both
collections of stories
and a novel called old 20th in his old
age he's becoming
even more prolific than in his youth and
that makes
an old man like me very happy and
inspires me
joe has has been a winner of a number of
awards including the riesling award for
poetry
and the james tiptree award for
exploration of gender roles in
speculative fiction
as you know he teaches science fiction
uh
uh writing and and uh this semester i
think a remarkable interesting course on
uh war stories war novels not only i
think science fiction
uh in the in the in the writing program
at mit
henry jenkins thank you very much for
that generous introduction
[Applause]
so uh we had agreed that joe would start
by doing
reading from some some of his current
work in progress and i'll let joe
just begin by saying a little bit what
you're reading and taking it away
okay basically i'm reading over there
okay because that's where i put it
i'm always after it occurred to me today
i'm always after my students not to
write science fiction set at mit
and i just did
[Laughter]
i've
in fact the day before i got to mit i
turned in this novel
this year called the accidental time
machine
and much of it does take place at mit
including the beginning which i will
begin at
the story would have been a lot
different if matt's supervisor had been
watching him when the machine first went
away
the older man was hunched over his
oscilloscope screen staring into the
green pool of light like a tweety and
corpulent bird of prey
fiddling with two knobs intent on a
throbbing bright oval that wiggled
around
eluding his control matt fuller could
have been in another room another state
sleet rattled on dark windows matt put
down his screwdriver
and pushed the reset button on the new
calibrator
a shoebox sized machine
the machine disappeared he stared for
about one second
when he was able to close his mouth and
open it again he said
dr marsh look dr marsh pulled all of
himself reluctantly from the round
screen
what is it matthew the machine had
reappeared
uh the calibrator for a moment there it
it well it looked like it went away dr
marsh nodded slowly
it went away i mean like it disappeared
gone samp
it appears to be here now well yeah
obviously i mean
it came back the big man leaned back
against the work table
tired springs on his chair groaning in
protest
we've both been up a long time how long
for you
well a lot but how long maybe
30 hours he looked at his watch maybe a
little more
you're seeing things matthew go home
he made helpless motions with his hands
but it but it go
home his supervisor turned off the scope
and heaved himself up
like me he took his thermal jacket a
bright red tent
off the hook and shrugged it on he
paused at the door
i mean it get some sleep something to
eat besides twinkies
yeah sure look who's giving dietary
advice
maybe it was the sugar though in the
coffee and a little little bit of speed
after dinner and
cold french fries and a chocolate chip
cookie and amphetamines
that might make you see things or not
see them for a moment
he waved goodnight to the professor and
sat back down at the calibrator
it was prettier than it had to be but
matt was funny that way
he'd found a nice rectangle of oak in
the miscellaneous storage bin
and cut out the metal parts so they fit
flush on top of it
the combination of wood with matte black
metal and glowing digital readouts
pleased him
he always looked kind of scruffy himself
but his machines were another matter
his bicycle was silent as grease and you
could play the spokes like a harp
his own oscilloscope which he had taken
apart and rebuilt had a sharper display
than the professors and no hiss
back when he'd had a car a mazda ibuki
it was always spotless and humming no
need for a car at mit though and plenty
of need for money
so somebody back in akron was despoiling
his handiwork on the mazda
he missed the relaxation of fiddling
with it
he ran his hand along the cool metal top
of the machine slightly warm above the
battery case
ought to turn it off he pushed the reset
button
the machine disappeared again holy [ __ ]
he bolted for the door professor marsh
he was at the end of the hall tying on
his hat what is it this time
matt looked over his shoulder and saw
the calibrator materialize again
it shimmered for a split second and then
was solid
uh well i don't guess it's really
important
come on matt what is it he looked over
his shoulder again
well i wondered if i could take the
calibrator home with me
what on earth would you calibrate he
smiled you have a little graviton
generator at home
just some circuit board tests i can do
them at home as well as here
thinking fast maybe sleep in tomorrow
not come in through the snow
good idea i may not come in either he
finished putting on his mittens
you can email me if anything comes up he
pushed open the door against a strong
wind
and looked back sardonic especially if
the thing disappears again
we do need it next week matt went back
and sat down by the calibrator and
sipped cold coffee
he checked his watch and pushed the
button the machine shimmered and
disappeared
but only the metal box the oak base
remained
a conical wood screw hole in each corner
it had done that last time too what
would happen if he put his hand in the
space where the box had been
when it came back it might chop him off
at the wrist
or there might be a huge nuclear
explosion the old science fiction
version of what happens when two objects
try to
occupy the same space at the same time
no there were plenty of air molecules
there when it came back before and no
obvious nuclear explosions
it shimmered back and he checked his
watch a little less than three minutes
the first disappearance had been about
one second then maybe 10
12 seconds his watch was a 20
dime store seiko but he was pretty sure
it had a stopwatch function
he took it off and pushed buttons at
random until it behaved like a stopwatch
he pushed the button on the watch and
the reset button simultaneously
it seemed to take forever the rattle of
sleet quieted to a soft whisper of snow
the machine reappeared and he clicked
the stopwatch button
34 minutes 33.22 seconds call it
110 170 2073 seconds
he crossed over to the professor's desk
and rummaged around for some semi-log
graph paper
if you took an average it looked like
the thing went missing about 12 times
longer each time you push the button
do the next one about six hours at home
he found a couple of plastic trash can
liners to protect the machine
but before he wrapped it up he put a
cardboard sleeve around the reset button
and fixed it in place with duct tape he
didn't want the machine disappearing on
the subway
it was one unholy [ __ ] of a night the
sleet indeed had turned to snow but
there were still deep puddles of icy
slush that you couldn't avoid
and matt hadn't worn boots by the time
he got on the red line his running shoes
were soaked and his feet were numb
when he got off at east lexington they
had thawed enough to start hurting
and the normal 10-minute uphill walk
took 20
the sidewalk slippery with ice forming
wouldn't do to drop the calibrator
he could build a new one in a couple of
days if he could find the parts
or his successor could after he was
fired
all the calibrator was supposed to do
was supply one reference photon per unit
of time
the unit of time being the tiny supposed
cronon
the length of time it takes light to
travel the radius of an electron
nothing to do with disappearing he
managed to take off a glove without
dropping the machine
and his thumbprint led him into the
apartment building he trudged up to the
second floor and thumbed his way into
his flat cara had only been gone for a
couple of days
and most of that time he'd been in the
lab but the place was already taking on
bachelor pad
aspects the stack of journals and
printouts on the coffee table had
spilled onto the floor and though he had
sorted through it twice
looking at things it hadn't occurred to
him to stack it back up
cara would have done that the first time
she walked through the living room so
maybe they weren't exactly made for each
other still
still he put the calibrator on the couch
and stacked the magazines half of them
slid back onto the floor
he went into the kitchen and didn't look
in the sink
he got a beer from the refrigerator and
took it into the bathroom along with the
new physical review letters
he ripped off his shoes and ran a few
inches of hot water into the tub and
blissfully put his feet into thaw
there was nothing in letters that
particularly interested him but it let
him pretend to be doing something useful
while he was mainly concerned with
falling out and drinking beer
of course that made the phone ring there
was an old-fashioned voice only in the
bathroom
he leaned over and punched it here
maddie only one person called him that
why can't i see you
no picture mother i'm on the bathroom
phone
i'm sending you money so you can have a
phone in the bathroom i wouldn't mind a
phone in the bathroom
it was already here it would cost extra
to take it out
well use your cell i want to see you no
you don't
i look like i've been up for 36 hours
because i have
what you're killing yourself you know
that why on earth would you stay up that
long
lab work actually he was disinclined to
come home to the apartment
to the empty apartment the empty bed but
he'd never told his mother about cara
i'm going to sleep in tomorrow maybe not
even go to the lab
he kept talking and pushed the hold
button down for a moment
call coming in mother buzzy tomorrow on
the cell he hung up and raised the beer
to his lips
and there was a perfunctory knock on the
apartment door
it creaked open he wiped his feet
inadequately on the bathroom throw rug
and stumbled into the living room
cara of course no one else's thumb would
open the door
she was pretty bedraggled pretty and
bedraggled
and had a look that matt had never seen
before not a friendly look
cara it's so good i finally stopped
trying to call you and came over
where have you been since yesterday
morning at
the lab oh sure you spent the night at
the lab forgot to route your cell
with the secret number even i can't call
i did
i mean i i didn't he spread his arms
wide i mean
i spent the night at the lab and they
don't allow you to route calls there
look i don't care where you spent the
night really i don't care at all
i just need something from the bathroom
do you mind he stepped aside and she
stomped by him dripping
he followed also dripping she looked in
the medicine cabinet and slammed it shut
then she looked at the tub you're taking
a bath in two inches of water
just uh just my feet oh of course of
course your feet
she jerked open the door you're weird
matt clean feet though
here she pulled out a baby blue box of
safe love contraceptive discs
don't ask she pointed a finger into his
face don't you dare ask
her face was flushed and her eyes were
bright with held back tears
i wouldn't she pushed her way past him
won't you just stay for a cup of coffee
it's so bad out someone's waiting she
stopped at the door
you can take my thumb off the door now
she paused as if wanting to say
something more
and then spun into the hall the door
closed with a quiet click
okay then a couple of chapters go by and
it turns out that he's got a useless
time machine
so every time you push the button it
just goes away and you have to wait
around and it comes back i mean
it doesn't bring you the stock
quotations or anything like that it just
goes away and comes back but but it has
something to do with reality and time
space continuum and this and that so
it's worth
investigating he tries he wonders
whether
he finds out that if he makes a faraday
cage just a metal box
and attaches it to the machine
whatever's in the cage will go
and actually it can even be open on one
side
so he tries it with a living thing he
goes out and buys a
little turtle at a pet store
and it comes back and seems nonetheless
though it's hard to tell with a turtle
and and so because he's
he is a weird guy and not particularly
responsible
and this and that i mean you wouldn't
recognize him from any of your
classmates i'm sure
but uh so he's there is one guy he knows
this is like a like 2060.
he knows one guy who's got a car
completely made out of metal
he has most or his income posits by then
he's got a
friend who's a dope dealer who's got a
100 year old thunderbird
like a 55 thunderbird dopey denny
and he's the guy that that matthew goes
to for
drugs that he needs for studying right
but they seem to have somewhat uh
a somewhat intimate relationship
dopey denny lived in a large three-story
victorian in back bay
he swung open the door and gave matt a
big hug 300 pounds of dope dealer
understandably stoned at nine in the
evening dr einstein i presume
he was wearing a black robe with
glittering astrological symbols tied
with the silver rope
barefoot in january hi denny he looked
over the big man's shoulder
louise home uh no no she moved on
how are you doing with what's her name
kara she moved on too
ain't it a [ __ ] want a drink i came
here to do
he came here to do science not socialize
but why not sure what you got
got it all he took matt by the elbow and
dragged him toward the kitchen
mat hauled along the duffel bag with all
his time machine stuff in it
the time machine moves an arbitrary
distance every time so he doesn't know
where he's going to wind up
if he winds up in boston harbor it's
going to be difficult in a
very solid metal car so he's got scuba
gear
and a big graph that he got at an army
surplus
anyhow so
i've got uh i'm doing heineken oh here
we go yeah
the kitchen was all chrome and tile and
looked like no one had ever cooked a
meal in it
i'm doing heineken with a whiskey chaser
or whiskey with a heineken chaser
you have one and i'll have the other
matt took a seat at the kitchen table
a spare elegant swedish thing there was
a bottle of 25 year old glenn maranje on
it and one crystal glass
denny produced another glass and got two
heinekens from a huge metal refrigerator
that seemed to have nothing in it but
beer and wine
he should use that for the time machine
it would be cold but he wouldn't die of
thirst
denny tried to twist the bottles open
then remembered they wouldn't work with
the imported beer and crashed through a
drawer until he found an opener
he put the beers down and poured matt a
generous amount of whiskey and himself a
little more generous one
he sat down on the delicate chair with
exaggerate exaggerated caution
so you see you say you need you say you
need
the tea the t-bird but just to sit in it
basically yeah he took a sip of the
whiskey and one of the beer
then it should disappear and then come
back he nodded slowly
like those guys who made the statue of
liberty disappear you know way back when
i don't know anything about that this
isn't magic it's well hell maybe it is
magic but
i don't know what the hell it is not
going to hurt the car
no way it just goes like somewhere
sideways in space
hell i'm going to be in it i wouldn't do
that if there was any danger would i
matt resisted the impulse to slug back
the whole glass that might communicate
uncertainty
then he took a vial out of his shirt
pocket and tapped out a small pile of
white powder
then produced a little cocktail straw
and sniffed it up he shook all over like
a big dog
want some no thanks haven't done it in
years
are you sure you can sure sure it's not
cocaine
it's a dd beta for alertness he shook
again grinning god damn
cuts to the chase this was just great
the soul witnessed to a scientific
revolution stoned on an untried drug
fortunately all he had to do was push a
button which was all matt had to do as
well
he took another sip from each reagent
how long have you been taking it
got it last night right up your alley
man work till dawn
maybe later after it's not a beta he
laughed you're a [ __ ] wild man denny
hey it's a job somebody has to do it
matt unzipped the duffel bag and brought
out the camera you know how to work this
yeah sure point and shoot right but i
want to make sure the time function's on
the clock down in the right hand corner
he toggled the switch until clock came
up and selected it
see danny denny took the camera no sweat
he held it up and looked at matt through
the point-and-shoot viewfinder
just pushed this big button right it'll
be on a tripod set for video
already aimed just start it when i tell
you to and if i disappear
leave it running till i come back maybe
in a taxi
he looked at the back of the camera no
picture
no use the viewfinder that's to save
power don't know how long
until i come back he heard his voice
quaver he really didn't know whether
he'd be back
he pushed the glass away better not
drink anymore changing the bathroom
he waved an arm back the way they'd come
mikasa sukasa
matt picked up the duffel and went down
the hall the bathroom was italian tile
with gold-plated hardware and a shower
curtain by salvador dali
or lately he framed nude paintings matt
unzipped the duffel and laid out his
gear
stripped and threw his clothes back into
the bag wallet and keys and changed in a
plastic bag which he would carry into
the uncertain future
the wetsuit was talcumed on the inside
and slid on easily
how would he explain it to denny just
that he didn't know what to expect
denny would probably not be able to
understand under the best of conditions
the tensor calculus he'd used as a shot
and a dark guess for describing the
thing's behavior
and these were not the best of
conditions he opened the chinese
carryout box and looked at herman the
turtle
who stared back accusingly he couldn't
leave him at home
he couldn't and couldn't leave him with
his mother with no explanation
he probably had a better chance of
surviving hurtling into the unknown in a
56 thunderbird
than risking denny's pet sitting
abilities
he put the char of baby the jar of baby
reptile chow
in his blouse pocket and picked up the
time machine along with the case of
bottled water and the bright yellow
square of emergency raft
and walked back into the kitchen holy
[ __ ] denny said
i'm swearing off the stuff he blinked
twice slowly i could swear you were
standing there in a scuba outfit
just just a wetsuit i don't know what
environment where
i'm going into it couldn't afford a
spacesuit you're going to
[ __ ] outer space no no nothing like
that the last time i used this machine
it moved but but less than a millimeter
he held up his thumb and forefinger
so not outer space guaranteed no not
outer space
he hoped just the [ __ ] ocean you're
going to take my t-bird and drop it in
the [ __ ] ocean
no it probably won't move more than an
inch but just in case
you dump it in the [ __ ] ocean or the
charles or the harbor
look look denny i can't swim the
probability is almost zero but it scares
me shitless
that mollified him a little yeah me
neither he shrugged
if it was the charles of the harbor i
guess we could haul it back up
yeah no problem unless i drowned then i
wouldn't be able to tell you where it
was
[Laughter]
he nodded rapidly and stood up with
surprising speed let's do it
matt and herman followed him through the
kitchen and out into the garage
there it was a 270 horsepower dinosaur
gleaming
under a dozen coats of tahitian red
lacquer
it it's beautiful matt said new paint
job be careful with it
he opened the door and snapped on the
radio it started playing i'm mr blue by
the belmonts
matt unfolded the tripod and set up the
tr the camera so it
would be pointed at him in the front
seat
he put the machine and the rest of his
gear on the passenger side and hooked up
with the alligator clip
which is on the time machine to the
car's frame
hey and don't get any chinese food on
the upholstery
it's not chinese food it's it's a turtle
oh yeah well of course yeah
almost forgot he reached into the pocket
with a baby reptile chow and brought out
a three by five card with professor
marsha's name and phone number
anything goes wrong call this guy my
boss
professor marsh like in swamp right he
started to close the door but left it
open
if he wound up in water he wanted to be
able to jump out i'm ready if you are
just point and shoot
when denny punch pushed the button so
did matt he was suddenly blind immersed
in opalescent gray
he heard herman nervously scratching
around in his box
it was strange but not unexpected he had
time to wonder whether it would be a
minute 10 minutes 40 days
and then all hell broke loose bright
daylight dazzled him and a yellow cab
crashed into his open door tearing it
off and spinning into the oncoming
traffic
where it was broadsided by the slow
crawling number one bus
he was in the middle of massachusetts
avenue in cambridge outside of the plow
and stars pub
traffic was squirreling to a halt all
around him horns blaring
with a large loud bang the yellow raft
decided to inflate itself
he grabbed herman and scrunched out of
the car pursued by a wall of yellow
plastic
his wetsuit rather incongruous under the
present circumstances
morning rush hour with snow all around a
siren wailed and a large female police
officer came bearing down on him with
her ticket book flapping in the cold
breeze
officer he said i can explain
or could he she sniffed at his breath
are you drunk
a male voice yelled hands in the air put
your goddamn hands in the air
matt did and another policeman marched
toward him holding a really large pistol
at eye level with both hands
but i haven't done anything he said
inane lee just dropped an antique car in
the middle of mass ave during rush hour
you know with no tires those were still
in denny's garage
the man's pistol was homing in on matt's
nose ran the plate he said to the woman
the car's stolen
owner murdered what matt said denny
you have the right to remain silent the
woman said her own gun pointed at matt's
heart
anything you say can and will be used to
you used against you in a court of law
you have the right to speak to an
attorney
or and to have an attorney present
during any questioning if you cannot
afford
a lawyer one will be provided for you at
government expense
but but i didn't kill anybody including
the yellow cab driver who was very much
alive even though his nose was bleeding
profusely as he stomped
toward the three of them yelling
incoherently never losing her point of
aim
the woman reached up and took the
chinese carry-out box and expertly
thumbed it open with one hand
she peered inside a turtle
well matt said it's a long story
so mit the the story eventually winds up
with mit about 300 years in the future
where it has become the massachusetts
institute of theosophy
and the world is rather different
so why don't we talk a little bit about
the representation of mit in
in the book uh you you mentioned to me
the other day you deal with mit in a
variety of different historic
periods both past present and future
well i had a lot of fun looking back
about the history of mit before it came
here when it was over on the other side
of the water
and it was a very you know
forward-looking
outfit and uh and actually in its way
conservative team
i get the impression from reading the uh
publications of the
1880s 1890s that they were
kind of watching out for the religious
types and the
politically conservative types even in
those days and so
uh i don't know i i have course lists
and i have
degree programs and everything from the
old days and it's wonderful all this you
know
electrical science and so forth they
were doing and
so the last part of the book he he comes
from an
unimaginably far future
and they can take him back to where he
left
with with precision but the time is
is kind of squishy or you can take it
take him back to the exact time and the
space is a little squishy
and they say you know do the former
rather than the ladder because you don't
want to
wind up exactly where you were but in
the middle of a concrete wall
so he goes back and winds up in at mit
about 10 years before it moved over here
and he's in an interesting position
because he was a physics graduate
student
uh just predoc uh back in the real world
and now he's
like 25 years before einstein
and he can sit and derive general
relativity
on the back of several envelopes and
but he doesn't because he's got no past
he just suddenly appeared
with his girlfriend who he stole from
the massachusetts institute of theosophy
and uh and so they've got no pants
they've got to work their way up he
starts as a janitor at mit
and and winds up some years later
getting degrees and
and being a professor who's a very
careful professor because
like he can when he when the first
papers about the electrodynamics of
moving particles come out
he can do the math just like that he
could do that when he was an
undergraduate
when the first tensor calculus
descriptions of general relativity come
out
he's got him cold that is he doesn't
discover things but he can explain
things to
everybody and he's sort of a grand old
man of the physics department
which is okay by him because he had been
a beleaguered graduate student before
and i don't i just have a lot of fun
with the sociology of
of being in this joint
well you touch on something that's
rather an under noticed aspect of
science fiction which is it's a
literature about scientists or science
people engage in the pursuit of science
so you have to think not just about the
science itself and speculation but
how you represent how people do science
what kinds of people do science
well and i try to be realistic about it
because i've been around scientists
since i was an undergraduate
and i know that they're misrepresented
in
in fiction uh for one either
on the genius side or on the crazy
person side and so a lot of the
scientists most of the scientists in my
in this story are like people i've known
one is one is a nut case who steals the
nobel prize from our friend
and our hero dr marsh winds up being not
such a good guy
and uh and gets a nobel prize in his 70s
for
the work that our hero did
but he gets back at him
the great thing about being a novelist
is anybody who ever did anything bad to
you
you can get him sooner or later
so early on in science fiction the the
the scientists protagonists would have
been a lone
tinkerer inventor increasingly it's
represented as corporate science a
science and a research institution
how does that change the kinds of
stories science fiction tells as we
rethink science is more of an
institutional rather than individual
pursuit
well actually you have to rethink what
the satisfactions of science are
and i think that one thing one reason i
didn't stay in science was my
realization that i wasn't going to be a
alone hero
of astrophysics uh
it was it was teamwork back then it was
in the 60s
and i realized too that my attraction to
science was aesthetic rather than
intellectual
and i'd better bail out really fast
before i had to take another
differential equations course
but these guys the people who actually
do the work it requires tremendous
intellectual discipline without
with the the handicap of being extremely
difficult to explain to anybody who's
not in your discipline
i mean even to the extent that somebody
who's a
biophysicist and somebody who's a
crystalline
magneto hydrodynamics person they have
to talk in undergraduate terms to each
other because they
don't have a professional vocabulary
that matches both of their
specializations
and you've got a you know if you're
writing a realistic story about science
even in the present let alone in the
future you've got to
recognize that it's it's extremely
compartmentalized
and you know you you try to be an
individual you try to be a
an educated person you try to have a
general
scientific and all around education but
i'll tell you
a person who's actually involved in in
the thin edge the wedge the top of the
wedge of research
i don't know when you have time to learn
chemistry and philosophy and music and
art and
and everything you know we hope that in
four years here we can
at least make you somewhat civilized but
i don't know
just look at the result what can i say
well it strikes me the character in the
story you just read from as a hybrid of
the two in the sense that he's working
in a lab he's under a supervisor
yeah what he's doing in the end to make
the story happen is his own work
yeah outside of the system going beyond
known science
he's modeled after an mit student i
never met but somebody told me about
the guy who was i guess at the master's
level and
would not get his doctorate and he was
working in
labs making machines and just
he was he's wonderful with his hands he
could do glass glass blowing and
he could do electronics he'd do anything
with his hands and that was he was
he was like a garage mechanic for
science i thought god what a story
a person who has moved sideways away
from specialization
into almost craft element of science
and so uh you know i decided not to go
all that distance because that's what
that would be what the story would be
about and i wanted to write this time
machine story
so i just gave him some of those
characteristics
well you you're mostly associated with
hard science fiction which is
a genre that is very deeply grounded in
science
we were talking the other day though the
time travel stories have had a kind of
odd relationship with the hard
sf tradition well that's the thing i
mean nobody's ever demonstrated time
travel but time travel stories are
automatically hard sf
whereas werewolf stories for instance
are automatically fantasy
but we have observed people
exhibiting werewolf-like behavior i mean
it's it's not because they're werewolves
it's because they're crazy
but uh but that would be a hard sf story
because it was based on clinical
observation likewise vampirism you know
you can
they're all sort of especially now the
post muffy crowd oh my god what's going
to happen
but no it's a it's a funny thing how
this is arbitrary because time machines
are machines i think
they are associated with hard sf
of course time travel has been described
in various
uh motifs and in higher mathematics
nothing that most nothing that layman
could understand nothing i can really
understand am i going to read the
descriptive article and say oh yeah
that's
that'd work but i can't do the math
anymore
yeah i have to say i was embarrassed at
the differential equation level a couple
years ago excited to do a simple
differential equation to
to figure out how long it gets to it
takes to get from point a to point b
and i had my old differential equation
textbook
and i read through the canonical
equations and i knew what i was supposed
to do
but 20 years is too long to leave
something like that alone
i called up greg benford
[Laughter]
benford works as a physicist yeah yeah
he's a
full professor in physics at uc davis
so he he still knows those things
yeah well the the hard sf distinction in
part grows out of hugo gernsbeck's
original conception
of a literature that popularizes science
the literature that
could be part of the popular education
of people at a time of enormous
technical and scientific change
in american society the early 20th
century his idea was that we'd have
a literary form that made those ideas
more accessible to the masses and it
would be a kind of democratic
approach to science education at one
point guernsback
speculated that he might print all the
scientific facts in a story in italics
so students could separate out readers
could separate out fact from fiction
and then he realized that actually there
was a value in the speculative dimension
of science fiction that not being sure
sorting out the line between science
fact and science speculation
was part of the educational value of
this that it was about problem
what we call sound debugging or problem
solving or speculation that the
community around it
had important functions to play well
gernsback was an interesting character
because he
felt that the the only use for science
fiction was to
turn young people into scientists and
engineers i mean
try to sugarcoat it a little bit so
they'd read it
but he he couldn't tell good writing
from bad i mean quite literally
and it's not as if any of my students
are that way either but
every now and then you run into somebody
who can't tell good writing from bad
and i think about good old hugo who uh
the thing about science fiction which
has been true since 1920
god 1898 is that uh
it's it's a form of writing but it's
also a way of looking at things it's a
it's a
mode of thought and so you have this
paradox that something can be pretty
damn good science fiction and be awful
writing really
terrible writing to the extent that you
or i as normal human beings
can't read it i mean can't
i can't read the foundation trilogy
anymore which i loved when i was 12
years old
i just can't you know my eyes lock on it
i said why did he do that
and it's true with most of the really
old stuff
i can read it as uh as raw material
i can read it to see where i came from i
guess
but ew ugly stuff
some of the ideation was very good and
some of the ideation
for instance may have saved us from
being dominated by nazi germany
back in back in the day uh
all the people who want well all the
people at pina monde where they made the
v buns and v2s were science fiction fans
so you can't generalize
they all had their astounding magazine
uh subscriptions and
and they were sure that after they got
rid of england they would go to the moon
but
it didn't work out that way fortunately
but the ones on our side who got radar
and the atomic bomb
and all the things that we needed in
order to save the world from nazism
they were science fiction readers they
were that kind of
guy and it was guys in those days almost
all of them
yeah well you many you knew many of
those pioneers that you were saying the
idea of going back
to hamilton even edmond hamilton yeah
what a nice guy
and jack jack williamson who just died
about three days ago 98 years old
uh i mean he and ed hamilton
went down the mississippi together on a
motorboat back in the 1920s early 1920s
and i thought by god what conversations
those guys must have had
you probably none of you have read
edmund hamilton because he's so
old-fashioned
but he was he had the huge imagination
just you know
galaxy-wide science fiction tales
and jack is jack or was jackie
he he was the guy who came up with the
idea of terraforming
uh he was the guy who came up with the
idea of contra-terrine
matter using matter animator as a fuel
source
and uh just the last time i i just wrote
his own bit so this is in my mind
but the last time i saw him i was at his
house in bertallis new mexico
where he taught at the small university
and he was 96 or 95 at the time
and we were sitting having a glass of
wine
and i was talking to him about
gravitational lensing in globular
clusters
and the implications that had for the
formation of planets
in general and we also talked about
aspects of asteroid mining comparing
carbonaceous quadratic
asteroids to the metallic ones and jack
knew exactly what i was
talking about he'd read the same
articles i had
he's just he's a science fiction writer
man
there are a lot of people who write sf
now who
wouldn't know a carbonaceous chondritic
asteroid from
their has but
but uh he's the old school and there are
a few of us who read it
who wouldn't know that either i have to
say yeah
so you're leading to this question of
the science fiction writer as a consumer
of
science research yeah and we talked
about this a little bit the other day
your relationship to existing bodies of
scientific knowledge could you say a
little more about that
well i wouldn't say it's research so
much as observation
well a good ques a thing in point so i
read like new scientists
and scientific american and those you
know fairly accessible things
and so like three days ago what was
tuesday whatever
coming back from teaching on the t i had
the
new new scientist i was going through
you know as you do
and i found this article that holy cow
this woman with her team of party
researchers
had compressed water like thousands of
atmospheres
and bombarded it with x-rays for six
hours
not five but six hours and
the result was an alloy of hydrogen and
oxygen metallic hydrogen
and oxygen now i'm going
whoo you know we never came up with that
and
uh so i the first thing i did when i got
home was i googled it and i found her
actual initial paper and verified what
it was and then i put it on my blog
saying can you believe this [ __ ] man
because this is the way i did chemistry
in junior high school yeah you could
just see them in this
lab saying well we've got this thing
uh why don't we put water in it and
crush it down like diamond
pressure and then while we've got it
that way let's just put x-rays on it for
about six hours and see what the [ __ ]
happens
i almost blew up my high school
chemistry lab
but i mean well after i read the paper i
realized that they were
indulging in some journalistic
shortcutting because actually they had
some idea of what was going to happen
but the thing we were so surprised well
[Laughter]
yeah it didn't i wonder whether we could
make an alloy of hydrogen on oxygen if
we
no i don't think that was in their mind
but uh
but it's gonna you know it may wind up
20 years from now that may be what you
put in your car
to fuel the fuel cells because you just
scale off the hydrogen
and you know run with it they're looking
for some way to get hydrogen
out of the dirigible down into something
that they can
slide into a fuel cell and go
so you read this article how does as a
creative writer what what kinds of
responses does that trigger for you
as well see my immediate response was
social i can i could just see
her and her gang of idiots going hmm
okay you've got the diamond-like
pressure here why don't we just
x-ray the damn thing and see what
happens i mean oh god i don't want to be
in a
same county as them but
[Laughter]
yeah but no it happens
the thing is i actually i get more damn
ideas out of popular science magazines
uh i don't know i had to make up a new
i wanted to okay i wanted to come up
with a new kind of alien
nobody steal this okay i can't
but i was you know this thing at the
museum of science with the
the plasticized dead people they cut
open and it's all very fascinating
and really gory and horrible and so we
went over there and we looked at this
and
real interesting and and it's full of
philosophical statements about life and
death and blah blah blah and so forth
so i'm i'm trying i'm fiddling with this
novel that i'm going to start december
8th
and uh i needed to come up with a new
kind of alien
so i said here's one everything in the
world is either alive or dead
right what if these aliens
are somewhere in between and they're
just they're really just
not alive or dead and maybe they don't
even know quite the difference they
don't appreciate the difference between
things that are alive and dead
how could i get there and i happened to
read
sky and telescope i was going through
flip flip flip
about uh forms of life that wouldn't
necessarily be carbon based
and there's one the way backstory is
we've known that silicon forms uh
compounds analogous to organic compounds
with
uh solutes that are pretty toxic like
hydrogen fluoride and
hydrochloric acid and so forth aha what
i didn't know was some people have been
doing work
on analogs to those that are done
in liquid nitrogen like
organic chemicals that can only exist at
400 degrees below zero i'm going
they'd be pretty slow wouldn't they
and so what about you know you take the
people from the museum of science
and the people who live in liquid
nitrogen and you say
maybe they are [ __ ] dead most of
their life you know
maybe they're just sit around somebody
pushes the button and they're alive for
a while
and they do their thing which takes like
10 000 years
and then they go dormant for a while
again
and then a hundred thousand years later
they say oh wake up mac
you know he knows the answer to this and
they push the button again he's alive
again
and you get these people up against the
human beings who are like mayflies to
them i mean
our lives are so so brief
that they uh they can't communicate
directly with us they have to
communicate through intermediaries and
so i have a scaled
bunch of aliens and these old
old cold things that live in liquid
nitrogen and live for millions of years
they've never died
i mean they know about death but none of
them has ever died i mean god think how
long that would take
at 400 degrees below zero how would you
know
and so they're but they they build like
like genetic engineering they build
these creatures who live shorter and
shorter lives until finally they have
one
that lives in a pool of liquid nitrogen
on triton
you know one of the satellites of
neptune
and it only lives like 10 000 years and
it kind of
can communicate with us like uh
[Music]
you got a point and
basically i'm thinking about trying to
communicate with people who are really
old
and so there's there's an element of
that in it but also
the idea that life can exist on all
sorts of time scales
depending on the chemistry of the life
i mean the biochemistry that that
mediates the life of a mayfly is so
different from ours
and it may fly mayflies basically you
know they
they sit around some nymph thing for
months at a time but when they become
real and mayflies
they may live only a few hours and they
never eat
uh yeah they got milds but they're left
over and uh they just made and die
you know once that must be a lot of fun
but uh
now what is their life like i'm saying
see what the aliens are going to tell us
is because they'll know about mayflies
they know about everything they've been
listening to radio and television
ever since it began and and have been
thinking about intelligent life for a
long time
they say if you had to communicate with
the mayfly what would you do
you'd have to build something that moved
a lot faster than you
and then have it built something moves
faster than it had it moved
some you know all the way down until you
had something that had the same lifespan
that for two two hours it could speak
the same language
and then you have to get a common
language the thing is
these aliens who whose representative
lives in this
lake on triton have done it before and
then we find out
that the trick is everything is sitting
on earth it's all predetermined
because they don't know what we're going
to turn out to be
and if we're dangerous they have a
little bit of prophylaxis they can do
you know to protect themselves and it's
already in place
they have to see how what we do and what
we are
and we can't tell because their science
is so
hugely sophisticated we can't even tell
it's science i mean you can walk right
over one of these
guys and think he's just a glacier
and so you know science fiction
science fiction happening in front of
your very eyes
[Laughter]
so so in the piece you wrote for the cms
newsletter you you describe
a bit the re the mission that science
fiction has
at a time when science itself is under
assault and i wonder if you could say
some things about
your vision of that well i'm kind of a
nutcase about it i don't know whether
you want my vision
yeah i just think that religion is out
of hand
on a lot of different levels and and
science fiction is a tool against
religion
i didn't say that i didn't say that but
you know there you go
science fiction is tool for rationalism
and for the rational approach
to solving life's problems and
you know i've got to admit things like
faith-based initiatives work really well
like you know 911 was a faith-based
initiative and that
changed all of american life you can't
say it doesn't work
it really worked and i just think that
maybe we can come up with something
that's more abc
and a little more maybe not as
interesting
but a little safer and science fiction
looks at alternatives science fiction is
like like a flight simulator
it's like a machine where you can go in
and try things out
without dying or you can just see
maybe what would happen if things were
this way or that way
and try to convince people of the
results
i mean when al gore did this movie you
know uh
quest the thing about questions an
inconvenient truth
an inconvenient truth yeah that was so
30s science fiction
because uh you know we all know that i
mean
i mean there are a few heretics who say
the world is actually getting colder
but uh it was fun to watch this guy
who's just uh he's not even a scientist
he's just kind of
a guy who got the the message and he's
doing a hugo guerns back thing on the
rest of the world
and he climbs up says this is where the
curve will go if you don't watch out oh
my god and i just thought it was
it was an interesting injection of a
kind of old-fashioned science fictional
tool into more what it pleases us to
call real life
so i think i really think science
fiction is more like real life than most
of the stuff we walk through
so let's we've so far been talking about
the science part of science fiction but
what about the literary dimension of it
i mean
you talked earlier about there being
stuff that's good science fiction and
lousy fiction
yeah um part of the complaint has been
the absence of characterization or vivid
characterization a lot of science
fiction
but the piece you just read is very much
a character sketch
well most of my fiction is
character-driven uh
and partly i don't know it's you re you
write what you'd like to read and i get
so bored
with these cardboard characters going
through and and
essentially giving a lesson and then
they
you put them back in the box and take
them out for the next [ __ ] novel you
know it's so boring
it really is you don't have to do that
you don't have to do that because you
can do it both you can have two bowls in
the air if you have one bowl in the air
it's not juggling is it
so uh yeah you can do both and the
the best science fiction writers have
done that and since wells and veron i
mean
i recently reread war of the worlds and
who didn't
and i was impressed by what he was doing
you know this is about the time that
henry james came up with the idea of
viewpoint
in fiction and he did so well just
saying oh well you know how many ways
can i tell this story
and the tension and the fear and
everything they brought up through the
various points of view and
just really good stuff more than 100
years old
good modern stuff i'm modern with little
him
and so now we're post-modern and we're
whatever is beyond postmodern now i
guess is
what we're trying to do uh
i don't know see i guess i'm really sort
of stuck back in the 1970s
i'm a hard science fiction writer who
appreciates
new wave kind of sensibilities and and
the necessity for
telling an actual mature story at the
same time as
doing a science dance
well i happen to know you're a big fan
of hemingway and he's been an important
influence on you so what what did
hemingway teach you as a science fiction
writer
um well hemingway hated science fiction
and fantasy and and anything that wasn't
you know that wouldn't grow hair on your
chest
[Laughter]
science fiction instantly makes hair
fall off your chest
it's good for women women should read
science fiction
now hemingway basically by example
rather than precept
i've i've read i hesitate
to say all of hemingway but i've read
all of the legitimate hemingway and most
of the
crap that they brought out to make some
money and i'm a member of the
international hemingway society have
been for a long time i go
listen to papers i even give papers
every now and then you know
yeah you've got i think a writer should
be fascinated by some writer
and i'm not sure it matters which writer
you absolutely are
enamored of i mean i really really know
a lot about hemingway and i think that's
by that's a way to say i know a lot
about writing through this filter
it's like in in optics you have you can
have limited band pass filters
that can tell you a lot about something
that you're looking at
you can tell like you get a hydrogen 3
filter and you look at this
cloud of gas out in the middle of the
constellation cygnus and you see a thing
that nobody could see without the filter
and you take the filter away and you see
what everybody else is saying you can
click like that like that
it's like i can i can read something
floored like faulkner who i think is a
great writer
but i can look at him through the
limited bandpass filter of hemingway
and say i can almost tell you how
hemingway would have written that scene
it wouldn't have been better but it
would have been hemingway
and you can also you can do it the other
way around and i i wouldn't dare to
because i'm nothing like a faulkner
scholar and
not really not really a hemingway
scholar either but
the idea that that the thing that makes
reading and writing infinitely
fascinating
is this idea that everybody brings his
own
set of filters to every situation
whether it's fictional or real life
real life sucks but you know
fiction inventing things you can invent
you can take a single scene and tell it
so many different ways that
fiction is almost endlessly fascinating
i'll tell you
you may have had exactly the same
experience because we're of an age
but when i was in the fifth grade and i
was fanatic about comic books i was
reading comic books
all the time somebody came out with a 3d
comic
that was a western and it just had one
scene in it which was an encounter in a
bar where this tough guy comes in
and he tries to hassle everybody in the
bar and the sheriff
draws down on him and they shoot the
sheriff kills him and and then goes
through this existential problem
afterwards
and then they go back to the beginning
of the story and they tell it again from
the outlaws viewpoint and then they go
back again and they tell it again from
the viewpoint of somebody who's just
sitting at a table
they did four or five iterations of the
story and because it was 3d and all very
modern and new
you had to think about it and like i'd
never heard of henry james i don't i was
10 years old
but i suddenly knew all i ever had to
know about henry james
or about viewpoint in the end and
i don't know it's just it gave me it was
like it was an epiphany
about storytelling before i had ever
read very much you know i just read a
bunch of science fiction
and some dickens and you know the things
you had to read in school but suddenly i
knew
that this was not even a finite
university
for every story there are another 7
billion ways to tell that story because
everybody who reads it sees something
different
yeah so one of your chat one of your
tasks here at mit is to teach mit
science students how to write science
fiction
so what what what are what are the
challenges of helping them translate
what they know about science
into storytelling well one problem is
timidity
uh people don't don't people who are
actual scientists and
especially fledgling scientists are
cautious about
about using that and so i'm not cautious
at all i just say anything
thing and if somebody says i'm wrong i
can go hey
i'm not a scientist but they can't do
that
i think there's a there are a couple of
problems one
i have to keep telling myself i'm three
times as old as these people
you know and i've been reading science
for
55 years and
i know a lot here and there i don't know
a lot about any one science but i have
this kind of
potpourri of of knowledge that they
don't have because they haven't been
reading general science for half a
century
and so i get impatient because somebody
who's a biochemist doesn't know
uh orbital mechanics
and i shouldn't be because they're only
so many years
to learn things and and so they're they
don't know they don't know
that's a problem but that's not their
problem that's mine
there's a distinct difference i've
taught at other places
and uh the distinct difference at mit is
that
most of the people you take who take
your course don't want to be writers
and uh you know it's a humanities course
everybody's got to have humanities no
problem
i mean i have no problem with it but a
person who's used to teaching
writing at some place like
harvard or someplace will go oh my god
they don't care they don't care about
sentence structure they don't care about
the music or the prose they don't they
don't care about this and that and the
other thing well
at news break they care about a lot of
things that
are much more important to them than
than the order of words in a sentence
and if you can't live with that you
shouldn't be trying to teach
at a place like this because you know i
can't like i can't get my ego involved
in the success of my students
as writers because they're not going to
be writers i've had what two students
uh in 23 years
who published books uh fiction books i
mean i'm sure they published
their own stuff but that's okay because
that's not my function here
but it sounds like from your discussion
that you see science fiction is a
generative space for scientists to think
about
possibilities they might not have
explored otherwise through their work
and there any number of examples of
concepts
in science fiction whether it's
terraforming or communication satellites
or
whatnot that emerged from science
fiction first and later became
substantiated part of the job for with
mit students
you know i would be so surprised if that
that happened to somebody when he was
older than 16 years old
i think by the time we get people here
they've absorbed the the root
nonverbal lesson of science fiction
which is that everything has changed
you know just keep keep open to ideas
new ideas and
and i think most of i very rarely
this happens but it's it's really rare
i'll have somebody who knows a lot about
science and has never read science
fiction
and they show up in classes you read
this and suddenly it's like they're 12
years old again
holy cow where was this stuff been all
my life well
i don't know i guess they were too busy
reading chemistry but
that can happen usually i get people who
have read some science fiction
or more likely nowadays they've seen a
lot of science fiction movies and tv
which is not an inferior form i keep
making myself repeat
but it's not the same yeah
uh the as as to the uh
function of science fiction in terms of
making people interested in science and
and
keeping their minds open and so forth
this is not the place value not really i
mean
most of my students already have that
when they
come to the first day of class and so i
teach it much differently than i would
teach a class at a
you know a normal university normal i
did i say we were not normal
no no we're not
shifting gears war has been a sort of
central theme running through your work
and it's an interesting theme because it
cuts across
your more realist fiction or your
autobiographical fiction writing and
your science fiction
writing and i'm wondering what the two
genres allow you to say about
the experience of war i'm not sure i
mean
uh once a writer starts to get that
analytical about his work i think he's
really headed for the rubber room or or
retirement now i uh i i understand
that well the basic fact is that
if you've been a soldier writing about
war is
the first natural emotional thing for
you to do
i mean it's going to be the most
dramatic thing that ever happened to you
unless you really went off the deep end
after you
came back from the war and so when
you're casting about
you know nobody sits around and says
what will i write about today
but when you face the blank page one of
the things that you go to automatically
is the difficulty and the pain
and the moral ambiguity and so forth
that the that the battlefield gives to
you
and like most people who are veterans
the first novel i wrote was a war novel
everybody's got to get that one out of
their system
and then i wrote some more considered
war novels later on
and you know i don't care if i never
write another one but
it'll happen you know you look for stuff
and that keeps coming back i was a
soldier
for one year exactly 365 days
and what was that like 30 years ago more
than 30 years ago
40 i mean 40 years ago and it's still
much of it is still right there all the
time which i think is true of anybody
who goes through a traumatic experience
well war has been a long-standing theme
of science fiction well i think critics
have commented that your representation
war is some of the more realistic
and compelling uh well most scientific
science fiction writers were smart
enough not to get drafted
see so i i come up
i go to these science fiction
conventions and all the other guys who
are my age
who write science fiction and were
soldiers
are all right-wing nuts i mean they're
just
none of them was drafted man they all
joined i'm going
my problem was i i was accepted to
graduate school in physics
and the year before or the year after i
would have gotten out of the draft
but 1967 they rescinded that
that consideration and so i got drafted
just like
what and the yellow we're missing the
we're not getting anything through the
mics down here oh
no you're not oh we are oh now we are
okay thanks
oh hi mike
uh well yeah that was my
my basic problem was i was born the
wrong year that's the way it goes
there was one year this is the only time
in a recorded history and probably in
all the history of the
universe when the association of
university professors
had a came together and cooperated with
the department of defense
because what happened was in 1967 they
said
they were drafting people out of once
you got your bachelor's degree they
would take you away
and so there was nobody left to do the
dog work
there were no graduate assistants to
grade papers and clean bottles and
things like that
and the army was drafting these people
who had a degree and they wouldn't
follow orders
you know you would say give me ten
give me a hundred push-ups he says why
because i've got a uniform on [ __ ] you
man
and you know that's not you don't want
the other soldiers to listen to somebody
doing that
you want them to say oh i'm so afraid of
him and so that's literally what
happened for one year they said
okay what happened was the actually
i've got my story a little advanced
because it was that year
when i was drafted when all these guys
called out to college and instead of
going on to graduate school they went
into the army
and just gave the army hell is i'd meet
him every now and then they're sitting
around saying
isn't this like a dream i mean you know
man this is so
[ __ ] like a dream and i'm going can i
have some of that
yeah but then and then they
they went back to letting the graduate
letting the graduates do graduate study
and
and just drafting poor black people
which you know worked a lot better
i mean obviously we well we did lose the
war i mean you got to admit it didn't
work that well
but at least it kept
all your parents out of it or
many of your parents uh
now we have a different situation and
it's very interesting i'm in
correspondence with a lot of people who
are fighting
now over in the desert there and it's a
different crowd because of course they
all
volunteered or or at least they joined
the national guard and thought they
could get out of it
but uh so it's a different deal i mean
we were anarchy
we were just really bad we were talking
in class last night about fragging
officers
and you know that was like a sport in
vietnam
everybody had heard about it even if you
hadn't done it
it was kind of well it's you know hey
man you joined
it could happen to you and and officers
knew that there was that little problem
that you had to give a little
nowadays they don't do that i don't
think nowadays uh
well they're still fragging i mean
soldiers have always killed their
officers i mean who's your enemy
who's putting you in danger it's not the
guys in the other uniform there's the
guys
making you go to those people and so you
look back
behind you and say oops
[Laughter]
a little a little dynamic that happened
that started to happen around the turn
of the last century when
individual infantrymen had so much power
at their disposal that they could
actually dispose of their officers
and not leave significant evidence
behind
so so uh people have compared the
forever war with the heinlein
starship troopers yeah and uh sort of
seeing it as different generations
response to
the experience a war in the ideology war
and i'm wondering how conscious you were
when you wrote that book
of engaging with a critique of heinlein
and
you know i didn't think of it at all i
was writing it
just it's a novel i'm writing my i'm
finally writing my science fiction
vietnam
novel right i'm typing along and a
friend of mine read the first like
60 pages and he said wow you're writing
an answer to starship troopers
and i said what i said yeah this is an
answer to starship troopers look
that you've got people in fighting suits
and they're and i say hold it you know
you're fighting in a
a vacuum you're going to do this in your
underwear you've got to have a fighting
suit
or something and and yeah in fact
heinlein was a world war ii guy and i
was a vietnam guy so of course we just
like that but we got along very well
together oddly enough
he respected the fact that i had
actually been in combat and
got out the other end of it and i
respected him as being an old guy
you know i'm he's an old guy
and uh he was the kind of old guy that i
was supposed to be if i had grown up
right you know
go to annapolis and and uh become a
leader of men and all that
didn't happen but uh but he and i
had a sort of grudging respect for one
another and we'd have
meals together and i'd we'd help each
other out here and there
he's a really nice guy i mean he was a
real one of the old school
a real gentleman and some people have
argued that ender's game then is the
next logical response in that
in that conversation yeah it is it is
and and i'd love to see a
three-dimensional mapping of the various
uh
ideas in the three books i mean if
anybody wants an easy masters thesis
there you go
i mean scott scott was so far from being
a soldier that it's not funny and he so
he wrote this thing about a
a kid who's sort of like a prototypical
or embryonic mit student
who has all the power in the universe i
mean i'm sure
i mean that book is a lot so much more
popular than mine here
but scott's uh very strange
well that's not news if you've read the
book but
he's a mormon and so he's writing about
about wars that kill like billions of
people at once and
i'm going scott you know even i didn't
do that and i'm an atheist
and
he's an interesting fellow he came and
talked here of course a couple years ago
and i think the students very much
enjoyed
he's got a wonderful intellect he's uh
he's a fine guy
unfortunately you know he's got his
little band pass and i've got my little
band pass and never the two
show me all right well
i've been monopolizing the conversation
but we have a great audience out there
and i'm sure they have questions as well
so if
people want to make your way to the mics
on either side uh
we'll be happy to entertain entertain
some questions from the audience
or declarations if necessary
uh while up is this on could we yeah
while we're waiting for
i don't have a question but i have i
have a fact because you were talking
about
ender's game and for 30 years in my time
at mit i
distribute cards to my students when in
the first class asking them
to list certain information about them
in case we needed to get this was before
we could find their names on the net and
so forth
and when they finished listing the prior
humanities courses they've taken and so
forth i asked them to list
their three favorite novels and their
three favorite films
and for 30 years by far i mean 10 times
more popular than any other book that
appears on that list
is ender's game
[Laughter]
well it's interesting to complete that
cycle for your would-be masters thesis
corey doctro who's a
new hotshot science fiction writer has
now written a book called a story called
anda's game
that is from a gamer's point of view a
critique of cards ender's game
so there's a there's yet another cycle
of this dialogue that i was just walking
this through
yeah yeah um i'm not sure if this is
really
questions but i'm the absence of other
you know comments
um i mean like it's it's
always been like extremely interesting
to me like how um
the science fiction community like seems
to
have these novels like about like war or
um like like massive
like massive conflict as kind of
cultural
um touchstones like for instance like um
ender's game for for um
my generation and you know uh um
heinlein and your work as well obviously
um and
i was wondering
if you'd read um john
john scalzi's um yeah um
old man war because it seems to me that
that's probably like the newest kind of
incarnation of that at least
you know like in i'm in the field and
like like
i'm like what what your reactions to
that were
my wife read it she reads all the
science fiction in the family and i
thought it was pretty good
i haven't read it because he said he
hadn't read the forever war and i might
read his
until he reads mine understandable
i met more questions later but um you
know i'll leave this open for other
people if they want to come up
well nobody's here i need to think of
them first
okay so so while we're talking about war
what do you think
would be likely the impact of the
experience of iraq the iraq war on on
science fiction
i'm particularly thinking about abu
ghraib as a sort of issue that science
fiction writers no doubt
are starting to process or will be
starting the process
well you're seeing it of course uh in
short stories
which are the immediate uh reaction to i
think
underneath the table we're coming down
to hell okay why don't i move mine over
for the time being
here we go hello
yeah well i'm i'm processing it
once i finish the war the novel i'm
doing now i'm
setting one in the desert which i think
is going to be
the iranian continuation of the iraqi
war
and uh yeah they have to deal with that
it's so
more it was morally easier for my
generation which was mostly people who
were made to be soldiers
or break the law and so then you have to
define
just put yourself between two sets of
law but the people who
did all of the who have done all their
stuff in
iran all volunteered for it
and it's a profound difference
i mean even in world war ii the guys
didn't volunteer for
all of them okay all right
um i have another question if you don't
mind sure please um
i was wondering like what your um
take on writers who write about war who
have never actually been in
um wars or conflicts on them
selves because like my own reaction like
as
a writer who has never been an actual
war
thank god um it like is kind of
is kind of troubled because like online
like i want to be able to like write
about these terms which i think are
kind of like really important and
interesting but at the same time
because i haven't been through like that
kind of experience
it i mean it seems like there are
particular elements of it which i would
be unable to portray as
accurately as i might like so i mean
like and it seems like some people
who haven't been in war like take
like the opportunity of like writing
about war as an opportunity to like kind
of
make it and depict it like in this
extremely
glorious like clean light which doesn't
seem to look natural
to anything like which i've seen or read
about it there's a basic john wayne
thing but you know the touchstone here
is stephen crane
who wrote the best novel about our civil
war
and he was like eight when it was over
or something and
i think one of the most telling things i
ever read about the red badge of courage
was the
review in the london times
it was a bestseller in london before it
was even published in america
and a guy i guess an old boer war
fellow said oh yes mr crane is obviously
a veteran
of the american civil war but there must
have been something wrong with his
hearing
he got the sound of the bullets wrong
well he'd never heard one
so i got it wrong but yeah you that
this is a big you know your basic
fictional problem is uh
experience versus imagination
and of course it's big in science
fiction because most things you write
about nobody's ever done
and you have to imagine them but i don't
think that
i think that if you don't want to go out
and get shot at
you should read a lot of horror fiction
i mean see how other people have
expressed it
hemingway was never a soldier hemingway
wrote pretty damn good war fiction
and uh all the things he knew about
being a soldier were
from watching other people because he
was
he was uh you know the closest he ever
came to being a soldier was passing out
chocolates as a
member of the red cross in world war one
on the italian front
he got wounded and that's an important
part of being a soldier you know next to
dying that's
you know your important thing and uh
yeah so he was he romanticized in a
weird way
you know it wasn't yes sir yes sir kind
of uh
patriotism but it was more like if
you're gonna be a real man
you gotta put your balls on the line or
no that's kind of grotesque but
yeah so so some of the game designer
there's in the game design world there's
this expression the uncanny valley which
is to say the more you get the photo
realism
the more the minor differences stand out
of people and it becomes less
realistic and less complicated yeah
isn't that so you know as you're
thinking about time travel you have
enormous
latitude to write about stuff without a
great deal of accuracy because none of
us in this room as far as i know
have had experienced time travel but
there will your re many of your readers
will have experienced
war so this does you see a similar kind
of uncanny valley
in terms of getting accuracy to things
that are closer to the likely lives of
your readers
than things that are purely speculative
and imaginative or
do or is how does that work it depends i
i don't know
in fact there may be a profound
difference between readers and gamers in
this regard
but a lot of my experience came from
books i mean really
i know a lot more about the 14th century
than i know about the 17th
in terms of living there because i read
barbara tuchman you know a distant
mirror
and bang so i know she
she gave me that century and
likewise somebody who's only seen
uh sort of comic book and
uh facile sort of descriptions of war
probably couldn't i mean certainly
couldn't write as well about it as a
person who's read the
the great war novels uh
the reason stephen crane wrote says he
wrote the red badge of courage was he
read
zola and zola had been a soldier
i guess in the same war as stendal
and he wrote this thick romantic novel
about how
you know wonderful and horrible it is to
be a soldier and supposedly stephen
crane threw it across the room
he said i've never even been a soldier
but i could write a better war novel
than that
and so he went off and did it but not in
a weekend i mean he uh
he interviewed a bunch of veterans he
spent months interviewing veterans at
hospitals across the uh middle east
of the united states he interviewed his
brother who had been at
appomattox i guess and uh
i mean interviewed him for a week and he
just took all kinds of notes
i've seen his materials uh i
i'm not a crane scholar but i did write
a scholarly introduction to the redwater
courage once
and uh god man he he had piles of stuff
to work from
and well he was just a gifted guy he was
a genius
and he could take all this raw material
and
percolate it through his own personality
and feel the fear and feel the horror
and everything now you know nobody can
tell you how to have that gift
you're just born with it or you don't
have it
joe one question i have stimulated by
the things you've been saying is to take
you
sort of uh more deeply into the course
you're teaching and
not so much about science fiction but
the war novels you're teaching you just
talked about stephen crane as a great
war novelist
who are the other writers that you teach
or that you think
about war that you think very highly of
and why
well of course hemingway and norman
mailer
uh and
well i should say in the course i'm
teaching we're not teaching the war
novel as such but it's a course in genre
fiction
and i'm allowed to choose whatever i
want so i chose
novels about war in the various genres
and to
you know try to use that as a unifying
principle and also because i want people
to think about what we're
up against that's my my freedom as a
teacher
and well i've got
i did starship troopers that's a genre
about
a general novel about war i i did
the things they carried which is a you
know personal uh novelized
memoir which is a genre
i did master and commander
which is a totally alien vision of war
because everybody thinks
this is cool we can go die but you know
the french are going to die too so
hey
maybe if we're lucky more of them will
die than us and meanwhile we've got rats
and bilge
oh by george
[Laughter]
i mean this this is creepy war writing
you know
i know and uh and they're evidently
marvelous i mean
all these stuff i get googling about
them i can see that there are people who
live
to read those novels to get to that
pardon me yeah thanks for brian
well anybody named o'brien is probably a
good novelist
you know it's a
he just he did huge research into
the british navy and he claims that
everything that he uses as
scenes in his novels have at an analog
if not a
precise version in the annals of british
naval history
the annals of british naval history of
course would fill this room
in single space sheets of paper and so
he's just
he was just a tremendous researcher and
a guy who was absolutely
smitten with the idea of being a sailor
but he wasn't the thing is yeah you
gotta
i haven't read that much i've read
horatio hornblower
and there seems to be a difference in
that the people and
oh here's o'brien's books
it seems to me that when they have when
something really bad happens it really
seems to happen to him
that is there's not like a man is uh
found guilty of uh
not homosexuality but having sex with an
animal
and so he's to be hanged and the
officers are up in the folks alert
wherever they
folk around they say does this seem
quite right to you
yeah it was just a goat
no it's not right but you do have to
make an example of him otherwise they'd
all be doing it
oh well you know hang him
[Laughter]
and going and in this
in this case you know it's very strange
because these were written in a not
particularly liberal time
but evidently one of the higher up
officers
is we would say either gay or closeted
nowadays and everybody knows i think
except him and they're all going
behind their backs oh yeah he's he's
getting in the cat scuppers
isn't that whatever they said in those
days and uh
and the captain and his mate don't
really judge him they say well you know
that's a man's business
uh but if anybody finds out about it
he's got to go you know and i mean like
walk the plank or whatever they do
in those days i was very just really
curious because the guy
the he's not a true i don't find him a
tremendously skilled novelist the book
is overly long and it's so
full of info dumping it's painful to
read if you ever want to know everything
about
knots and sales and all that crap you
know
just sit and read every word of that
book man you could go
build a ship after you've written read
this book
and maybe that's not the way i write
novels myself
oh these blueprints
yeah well anyhow
yeah and i also did as a counterpoise to
starship troopers
i did the dispossessed by ursula le guin
because i wanted
novels about war and peace and the
dispossessed is a uh
well it's a didactic novel about
possibly having a world where war wasn't
not possible
by the proper indoctrination of the
population
and you get the old the old idea you
know you can have peace
but you can have peace and freedom at
the same time or you have to redefine
freedom that's what
what the gwen was saying very very
interesting
she's a wise wise woman
i disagree with her of course but i will
don't know
you know um
two two maybe related questions one is
what do you think the impact of
the internet has been on science fiction
um particularly blogging but also
you know virtual realities worlds like
uh you know sims and second life and
things like that
and secondly and maybe this is an
indication of
[Music]
myself getting old i sort of look at you
know the last 30 years and see how fast
technology and science has has evolved
and
wonder whether you know it's that much
harder to write science fiction
as opposed to science fantasy now than
it was
30 40 years ago or is that just you know
my perception it is more difficult and
what's what's gone is the easy
stories it's difficult to tell a story
set in the solar system now because you
know too much about the solar system
that is to say
you know to take you have to take you
may take a broad viewpoint and say well
i could write a story about the first
man on the moon if i wanted to
and just make it different from the one
that is history and so it becomes an
alternate history story and so you can
still
do whatever you want if you want to put
that kind of a spin on it
but in fact if you're going to do
anything like
on the edge of science you're
stuck with a lot of explaining you can't
assume that
everybody knows enough to get up there
on the edge with you
and unless you want to write just for a
wired magazine or
or whatever
it's different from when i started it
really is i mean i
my first science fiction story came out
in 69
and i wrote it in 67 and
the world was simpler than like you
wouldn't have i wouldn't have said that
at the time
the world seemed awfully complex then
but
uh yeah it's harder to write science
fiction now
well some people have noted that the
time frame of science fiction has gotten
shorter and shorter as the 20th
centuries run along so that
off staples to center someone would
write thousands of years in the future
and by today 20 minutes in the future is
far enough to envision radical
difference and significant technological
change and your audience is all aware of
the uh
of the importance of change in their
lives i mean
you like your grandfather's computer and
i came across that in a newspaper
article today you know
about the permanence of books paper
books is try to find anything that will
work on a computer that you had 20
years ago you know all that data that
you've got
i wrote a whole a whole screenplay
uh for mindbridge one of my novels
and it's on five and uh the the little
floppies that came before
the big fobs game before the five inch
ones the eight inch lobbies
and it was a uh a language called doctor
memory
which has been forgotten and i tried to
find some
place in this hugely technological town
that could transcribe
doctor memory and put it into a word or
even some text file or
some unix thing or whatever they do
digital binary give me binary
nobody could do it and this is a whole
you know like three months work
translating a novel into a screenplay
it's just gone because i don't have a
paper copy anymore
so he was also asking you about blogs
and their impact on science fiction
we're both vloggers and
um well i've been i'm an a
a paleo blogger i guess because i've
been
i started i didn't call it blogging but
i started keeping a
an interactive diary in the late 80s
and when the genie network started
uh genie was general electric had these
big computers that were
more or less not being used
from nine at night until six in the
morning
and so they would uh you know partition
stuff and let us use them
as a sort of a primitive arp in that
kind of
communication and uh there was one set
off
for science fiction writers at a time
when there were only like 150 science
fiction writers around
and so we had a wonderful little uh
party going and it was a lot of fun but
you now i
i'd always read about writers should
keep diaries
you know obviously a writer must keep a
diary so you have a record of everything
and what was what bothered me about that
was nobody would ever read it you know
why should you write something if
nobody's going to read it
wine wine and so
i would write about a page in a diary
and then lose it and
a couple of months later i said oh [ __ ]
i'll start another one and i'd
write a few pages in that i'll lost that
one someday i'm going to find all of
them and put them together it might be
like 30 pages of diary covering
25 years but then this thing came along
and i thought you know we're talking
every day
so why not just keep a diary and say
what do you think about this
and basically that was the proto blog
and a lot of science fiction people do
it
uh i think dan simmons has the most
interesting one intellectually
mine is not intellectually that
interesting because i just i do it every
day it's my diary
but dan comes up with extremely
provocative
questions and throws them out to i don't
know a couple thousand readers
and it's interesting to watch that okay
question over here
you said uh that you're starting your
novel on december 8th
and the precision of that interested me
and i was wondering uh
how do you usually set up to start a
novel i usually uh nowadays
i used to be able to just write until
i had finished it oh what a wonderful
thing
i i try not to work on the text of a
novel while i'm teaching
it's difficult really difficult to do
both at once
they seem to engage the same sort of
sources of energy or whatever
so december 8th is when i turn in my
grades
and you know this is my life i finished
my last novel
on the plane i delivered the last part
of my novel on the plane
here in august i put it in the
mailbox in the atlanta airport and then
i came and became a teacher
and on december 8th i stopped being a
teacher
and i go back to being what i really am
you know this this all just i
i bought this tweed suit thought i could
fool people but basically
i'm a bum
[Laughter]
no it's a december 8th is going to be my
freedom day
what i've done i've got i know the novel
that i'm going to write and i've been
pitching ideas at this thing
for oh actually a couple
seven years and that's typical
because you don't just start writing i
mean
that would take a lot of guts to just
start a novel without any preparation
especially a science fiction model you
got to get the science worked out
that's funny i was reading a thing this
morning by jack williamson because i was
trying to get stuff to write for his
obituary
and that's the way he did it too you
know
first you get the science first you find
out where you are
and you get the whatever the themes are
you're going to be writing about you
know you don't know what that
really is it's it's something very deep
within you that you have to write about
so you don't
get specific about that on an outline or
anything
but you want to know where they're going
what they're doing what the year is what
their technological capabilities are
this and that and the other thing is
there's something you know really really
different about the way that the
human relations go and so forth and so
i'm just sitting there typing man it's
what i love the computer for
is that i can just spread all over the
place and i've got notes that are
hyper text to each other and go back and
forth and i'm just a real 21st century
guy
until i start writing the novel which i
always i write
literally by candlelight with a fountain
pen
and blank books i write one
draft that is a novel i write a book
like
they would write a book in the 12th
century
and i don't know why i mean it's just
the only i've always written that way
i tell my students don't do this don't
listen to me don't do this because
you're supposed to write this long
rough draft and have fun doing it and
then you cut it down to something that's
about a fourth as long and it's really
really crisp and everything
i don't do that i just write a line at a
time man i i might sit
it might take me two hours to come up
with the next sentence and i don't care
because it's going to be the right
sentence
and then i'll do the next one that's why
i've always done it
and i'm not the only one it seems to me
that something like
a quarter of the people i know who write
for a living do some version of that
but see writing it down in longhand
in a bound book means i have a first
draft
if i were typing it on a computer keep
on a keyboard
into a computer file i could call it a
first draft
i could call it anything but i couldn't
prove that it was a first draft
there's no provenance for it if it's
written handwritten into a
book then this first draft which to me
is important
because if i go back to something i
would like to have students take to
heart is
there's a problem working on a computer
and that you're you keep wiping out
things and replacing them and so forth
hell you might have had it right you
know
and two days later two hours later you
can't even remember what it was
whereas if it's down in ink and you
scratch over it
and write something else you still have
the original it's very very
high tech but uh but you don't lose
anything i never throw anything away
i've got i have a room full of paper
this is for my sins
but if i need to come up with something
it's in there someplace you know
it's there she she
organizes it sometime
by the story that william gibson wrote
neuromancer on him on a manual
typewriter
he'd never even seen he never owned a
computer he'd never programmed on
which actually is kind of obvious if you
look at it but uh
talk about people who write about stuff
that they haven't experienced directly
yeah alec you so um
i have one more question if you don't
mind um
earlier you were talking about
hugo gernsbeck's like idea that science
fiction
like in some way like ought to be um
a literature that
communicates the ideas uh and like i
mean like
not just like the raw like facts of
science but also i mean like the
kind of principles and processes and
i mean like to actually to choose a word
that's slightly
kind of weighted i mean the ideology of
science to its readers um
and i was wondering like what your
feelings on that
kind of like idea were i mean i think
you talked about that
briefly already but especially like in
con in the context of
science fiction's kind of positioning in
um today's marketplace of ideas where
what's what science fiction like is
represented as
on like tv and in movies like doesn't
really correspond
very well to what it tends to be in
books
and also like where
like science fiction as a literary genre
like
seems to be a shrinking portion of the
market for
um trade books oh yeah yeah well it's
science fiction like all fiction is
becoming less important
culturally there's this uh
ironic little interview with uh truman
capote no with uh
[Music]
the other old gay guy
[Laughter]
uh tennessee williams no no no i'm still
still alive
no still alive
you know somebody said are you a uh an
important novelist and he says there is
no such thing as an important novelist
now
he could be or a famous novelist you can
be a famous
movie star you can be a famous cook
but there are no famous novelists
because not enough people read novels
and this point i think a novel can still
change things because the people who
read them
tend to be people who are educated and
might
be in a position to change things but as
far as you know the kerns bankian thing
where
you wanted to preach science to people
and actually
take thousands of people and turn them
into scientists when they might have
been librarians or something
that's not there anymore and also the
the arguments the
you use the word ideology of science
which is interesting because
through the 60s and 70s science fiction
became anti-science or anti-tech
and there was it was almost difficult to
sell
a story that was positive about science
or about technology
because everybody had this uh negative
dream about how it was going to destroy
the world rather than save it
and now we're coming back around having
had our little fill
of faith-based initiatives
maybe people are starting to take a more
complex view of it
science isn't innately good or bad i
mean all of us know that
it's the people and the way that people
use science it's interesting
and uh that's i think science fiction
reflects that now
it's uh there's nothing that's uh is
black or white about it one of the
interesting things about science fiction
is the apprenticeship model that takes
place between professional science
fiction writers
and fans or readers where a high
percentage of science fiction writers
got their start in some sort of fanzine
publishing or some sort of
fan relationship to the genre and i
wonder if you could say a little about
that and maybe
suggest something of your own
apprenticeship how you became a science
fiction writer
yeah well i was i guess i had a little
apprenticeship
because i wrote poetry all my life and i
never
thought i was going to be a fiction
writer i thought i was going to be a
poet
and i knew that you don't make a living
at it and it was just something that
a passion that would never control my
life what would be part of it
but then i wrote some fiction actually
literally in the last semester of my
senior year in college and sold it i
thought
hmm beer money you know i could do this
and when i got back from vietnam and
i did a three semesters graduate work in
mathematics and the third semester i was
getting kind of
and i sold my first novel and so i just
bailed on that
and just i don't know became a writer
but
but the question was about
apprenticeship uh
see in that in that sense i didn't have
one my brother was a science fiction fan
i mean he was a fan with a capital ph
science fiction fan he had a huge
printing press
the size of this table almost the size
of this table in his basement
and he cranked out a fanzine that looked
as good as any you know industrial
magazine
it cost him all his all his money and a
marriage but he did
a wonderful fanzing and uh and yeah he
he did the whole nine yards he was he
went to all the conventions he met all
the
writers and he went to workshops and he
did this and that
and he wound up writing two science
fiction novels and
maybe a hundred short stories he didn't
make enough money to do it for a living
which is true with most
most people who go that route but he
pursued it with more intensity than most
people do possibly because his younger
brother was a success
i mean they could that could do it to
you
[Laughter]
but yeah what happens is what the
classical model is
science fiction writers have always been
conscious of having been helped by older
writers
and you pay it forward by helping
younger writers
to essentially replace you i mean that's
what it is
but you don't want to articulate it that
way because you don't
think of yourself being replaced but you
know you can always knock off the weak
ones on the way
you know we don't do that we knock off
the strong ones
so there's less competition uh
but there's a we've always been i don't
know i was helped by
a number of people remarkably ben bova
who actually made me into a writer by
intervening for me in some difficult
editorial situations
and you know he just knew more about
publishing than me and he said no do
this
and and he said let me write a letter
for you and
wow i've never had success with that you
know with uh with younger writers
i've never been able to say here i'll
just put on my cape and
i'll take over the situation and save
you
i'm not that kind of guy i say you know
i can fix your semicolons
just like that okay over here
i have another question about your
writing process how close are your first
drafts to what we see in print
almost everything that my first draft is
on my first
threat shows up in print probably 98 of
it
but often the editor asked me to expand
a section here and there
so i guess 110 of my first draft lines
up in print
yeah okay which is a terrible way to
write terrible way to write don't do it
and don't tell your writing teachers i
told you i did
oh i had to go talk to a third grade
class
in iowa city when i was at the iowa
writers workshop
and i was supposed to tell them how to
write stories and and they're all just
like this
they're just cute as can be and of
course their teacher is pretty cute too
but
she says well mr holdeman
how do you do you must outline your
stories before you write them don't you
i
i said no you just start writing
it's just no but first you have to have
a plan right you have an outline
[Laughter]
you know just paper is what it really
takes you just
write on the paper
[Laughter]
not what the third graders were supposed
to hear
okay over here
in your time travel story 300 years in
the future
is the star in plows still in cambridge
is the plow and stars still in cambridge
no no
actually that's only a year and a so
half
pollen starts the plow and stars was
there for a short jump
but when it goes way up into where this
is the massachusetts institute of
theosophy
uh mass ave is still there but it's a
cow path
and the harvard bridge alas fell in
and they've got a they've got logs over
it and they you know have to control
traffic because it's all oxen and so
forth
we have come to a pretty past by then so
they still paint smooths on the logs
[Laughter]
the great god smooth has been defeated
by 2352
okay well on that note i think we'll
bring this to a close
uh there's a books on sale joe's books
are on sale outside in the lobby and he
will shortly be there to sign
copies of books he'll linger here i'm
told for a few minutes to deal with
people
up front but thank you very much for
[Applause]
coming
you